human bodies are all beautifully
different and we're gonna prove it by
watching some tick tocks
what's a really weird thing that your
body does that you're not sure anybody
else's body does so i was just wondering
if anybody else can make their tongue
disappear yeah look now you see it
no you don't three
whoa
did it like fold back into her throat
she must have an extended soft palate or
something that she's able to just like
put her tongue all the way back in her
mouth
[Music]
it's not doctor's signatures that's uh
potentially varicose veins that's
actually a problem so veins the way that
they work in comparison to arteries is
their thin walled and they have little
valves in them that prevent backflow
sometimes when veins swell from an
overabundance of blood or perhaps from
gravity pooling what have you they could
sometimes get damaged and they don't
return back to their normal shape so
they look like that
that's so cool i want to be able to do
that
i can't do it whenever people have
unique control of their bodies i get so
jealous because i cannot do anything
remotely special except touch my nose
with my tongue
i can't anymore
i used to be able to
[Music]
interesting yeah uh lipedema is
frequently confused with lymphedema
lymphedema swelling from the lymphatic
system lipedema is basically an
increased amount or accumulation of fat
tissue in a specific area and it's not
like that you could lose that fat tissue
i have two uvulas oh it's actually just
excess skin at the back of my throat and
it's quite uncomfortable and has been
for the last 12 years
uh-huh i see it huh it's almost like a
skin tag but in the back of the throat
it could easily pass for a second uvula
did you know that spine circles can not
only lubricate your spine but they can
strengthen muscle and tendon
coordination an accurate tic-toc
absolutely do spine circles like i i do
cat cow but this is like cat cow on
steroids do this this is amazing if
you're otherwise healthy and have no
other medical injuries kind of gotta be
careful on this i have three nostrils
told ya see i wonder if this individual
has just a septum there like an extra
septum meaning a separation and then it
continues and merges into one nasal
passageway or are there truly three
nasal passageways because i've never
seen that before i wonder what an ent
would say about this
can i do this all right i'm ready
oh wait what
no
that's not real i can't i can't imagine
that to be real there is a medical
condition where you have multiple pupils
but not like a full iris and all i was
born with a condition called
ectrodactyly oh it's almost like a they
call this sometimes a cleft hand almost
like a cleft palate and i don't have my
middle fingers which means yes i cannot
flip someone off
thank you oh she's doing the friends
joke this finger for some reason um just
and then this one too well that makes
sense she has an extra joint there so
she has extra mobility there so that's
interesting that's it i love my hands
and i think they're really cool love
your differences
[Music]
ooh worm
when i was on the doctor's show we
talked about this how you can get
loyasis which is a type of parasitic
worm that can enter your eye there are
treatments for this i can't believe they
got it on camera this clearly though
that's nice let's test my spice limit
again oh i have zero spice limit so i
already know i'm going to lose
tacos i don't know what a taki is what's
a taki holland cayenne pepper oh
remember the spiciness from peppers
comes from capsaicin it's the compound
that actually triggers that burning
sensation in your mouth no actual damage
is happening but it's tricking your body
into thinking that there's damage
happening so your body's creating all of
these reactions like the sensation the
sweating the the swelling
uh i could never do this
this is like extra and then going one
step past extra
no
no ah don't do it you know what all i'm
thinking about is like it's burning on
its way in
but it's also gonna burn on its way out
fun fact did you know that removing
caffeine from your diet can help you
lose please be accurate please be
accurate over 60 percent of your will to
live
[Laughter]
not accurate but funny quickly removing
caffeine from your diet can cause
withdrawal headaches
oh oh what
to
make
uh
oh to make a difference
oh
she got me foot dog dana always coming
in clutch
he braids his armpit hair i can do that
that's pretty weird no it's not i can
pull out my armpit hair too but it's not
going to feel good
oh
not fast enough that child
is going to be a pro athlete
he just gets hit in the face that's me
as a kid all the time i had the same
little hoop just in my like tiny one
bedroom apartment in brooklyn where i
used to dunk all the time and because it
had a springy like rim i would dunk and
it would chew right back into my face i
invented this pin8 when we need to pee
we activate the switch
will help us to hold it we don't need to
use our hands at all it also helps us to
shake a little
very easy to use oh man that's gonna
hurt i don't want it i don't want it
blister what am i looking at blister
blister oh blister that pop yeah don't
pop your blisters because within the
blister it's kind of a sterile
environment so you don't want to open it
up and create a potential source of
infection because remember immediately
underneath the blister like underneath
the pocket of fluid you have sensitive
skin there that hasn't healed yet this
is super weird um i can move my head
oh that's cool your scalp actually has
muscles that's normal actually do you
know why goosebumps happen do you know
why hair stands up on your skin because
of muscles
is that cool
okay so i'm 20 years old and i've never
met anybody else that's able to do this
show us
whoa
i can bend both my knees backwards and i
can take it to the side and bend it wow
she is really hyper flexible it's hyper
mobility not just in the knee joint but
also in the hip joint as well because to
do that whole rotation there i could see
that causing a significant problem uh
medically down the line that's why it's
important that your doctor understands
the risks that you face so therefore you
require individual care and individual
assessment of your risks to prevent
future problems or decrease the
likelihood of them so i'm attending
thrones so yeah
what it looks like i'm looking at here
is potentially clubbing of the distal
phalanges it's an enlargement of the
furthest part of your finger where you
actually have down sloping of the nail
as well this most commonly happens in
cancers related to the lung but it can
happen with heart disease as well also
some
malabsorption conditions also i'm
talking about secondary clubbing of the
of the hands if you have primary
clubbing of the hands that means you
just happen to be born like that and you
actually don't have a problem
oh
i think this is called syndactyly where
two fingers are actually attached and
never separated at birth it's a
congenital situation based on the
movement there it looks like a surgical
option would be possible and still
retain motion of both fingers based on
how it was moving i have been vegan for
two years due to allergies sensitivities
and medical reasons i have to start
eating fish i wonder why fish
specifically
i've never seen someone so sad to have
to eat fish i'm really sad
oh i'm guessing she was vegan for uh
ethical reasons
i'm literally having a breakdown over
this piece of fish right now i don't
know who this person is and i don't know
if they're acting here but if they
aren't i feel bad here
i'm gonna
find a joint in my neck
oh yeah dangerous if you have hyper
laxity like this in your neck imagine
you're involved in a car accident you
have a traditional whiplash injury where
you snap your neck back and forth
because you were rear-ended huge problem
here because there's not enough
supportive tissue here to prevent a
serious serious injury
oh splinter time splinter time jake told
me he had a splinter in his foot i hope
this is a doctor doing this i can't
really see what's going on get it like
oh that's a blade that's a type of blade
that we use in certain skin procedures
do like a shave biopsies oh my god oh
wow
is that blood i can't really see i guess
the x-ray wasn't kidding oh
that is a serious serious
serious i'm going to say one more time
serious splinter the first time i
actually moved into my home in staten
island i never had a big home before
that we lived like in a tiny box
apartment for like a decade i ran across
the floor this new wooden floor and i
slid in my socks i had something like
that go into my foot but it didn't go
all the way in i was able to pull it out
but it was the most painful experience
ever so from that moment on i said i am
never sliding on the floor with socks
again because i have a fear of that hope
you all understand me
questions
so what's that on your face no offense
for you it is called a metal rod where i
got shot right here the bullet came off
my neck a bullet and my jaw shattered so
they had to put these rods
in my jaw in hopes that my dremel
reconstruct itself well it does the body
does heal itself i mean i don't know in
this specific instance obviously but
generally speaking the body does a
fantastic job of healing itself imagine
a bone breaks you put it together even
though like you didn't put any glue or
anything it just starts healing isn't
that amazing hi me and my eyes hi riri
no rear you gotta check if the duck has
a pulse ask the duck if it's alive first
call for help reary that's really cute
though
wood sculpting breaks down cellulite
then we transfer the fat to the butt you
really think you could just move fat
around in your body imagine i'm like oh
this muscle is so nice you know what
let's just put it on here
no it doesn't work like that the reality
of cellulite is that it's near permanent
you have to go through drastic measures
to address it like laser procedures or
even surgical procedures so to say that
like you're just gonna do this and then
remove the fat come on now hey what's up
guys how to make your lady juice smell
and taste like heaven is that the name
of her concoction teach you how to make
your hoo-ha smell and taste amazing so
it's all about the ph depending on what
you eat it can taste really bitter or
you can also smell and taste fishy which
is not what you want
a vaginal odor that has a fishy odor to
it does not come from eating fish
man tick tock is so problematic first of
all a vagina should smell like a vagina
it shouldn't smell like peaches like
that's not what it's supposed to smell
like healthy vaginal ph is actually
acidic to some degree and that's the
normal vaginal ph and changes in that
vaginal ph can change the odor but it's
not
the ph that's changing the odor it's the
ph that's changing the microorganisms
that live in the vagina that change the
odor good morning i'm here for the
interview oh
oh
you're hired
excuse me
yeah you can have the job
i love this doctor this doctor actually
has an amazing story because i've read
that this doctor's heart stopped and his
wife actually saved his life by doing
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compress you know what after this
video i'm gonna email this doctor and
set him a chest compressions merch shirt
because i think it would probably mean a
lot more to him than it does to me what
do you think a typical work day looks
like for a primary care doctor fitting
12 hours of appointments into eight
hours then going home and charting until
i fall asleep at my computer
so the only thing i would change for
myself there is fitting 14 hours of
appointments into 10 hours and charting
at my desk at work before i fall asleep
i can't go home once i'm home i suck at
doing notes at home so i have to stay in
the office and sometimes it's so dark
it's so late when i'm leaving family
medicine is an amazing amazing specialty
there's so much good stuff to it but
everything
mentioned here is so spot on did you
have fun at the doctor you were
mentioning me oh we measured the length
of a baby the circumference of the
baby's head we weigh the baby he got me
some stickers i love stickers i love
giving stickers away yeah i didn't have
fun
in my head this is how all my pediatric
patients think of me it's definitely not
the case let's go back to the dog the
miracle of positive reinforcement and
you can give me some more stickers how
about the fact that we're helping you
with your health huh
it's not all about stickers
i'm officially going on tour i never
thought that this would happen here are
the cities that i'm visiting in april
i'm so excited to meet you guys i'm
about to blow the roof off these stages
by having a blast educating staying
happy and healthy so check out the tour
link down below get your tickets it's
gonna be a blast like if you you're not
gonna be there you're gonna miss out
there's actually vip tickets available
that are limited in quantity where you
get special merch items i may sign them
we'll take a photo together we'll meet
in person the tickets are limited in
quantity too so get yours now before
they get sold out i'm only doing these
four cities for now and click down below
the link is right there
doctormikelive.com
and if you drink green tea or you want
to know more about green tea here are
seven factually interesting facts i said
fact a lot of green tea click here and
check that out as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]
you